>> IT SOUNDS LIKE HE HAS A BIT
OF BEEF WITH THE COMMUNICATIONS
OFFICE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> NEW BOOK BY A FORMER TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION STAFF MEMBER
SHEDDING LIGHT ON A WHITE HOUSE
HE DESCRIBES AS ABSOLUTELY OUT
OF CONTROL.
>> CHAOS IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
THAT'S BEEN THE STORY FOR TWO
YEARS, ACCORDING TO REPORT AFTER
REPORT.
>> Juan: A LOT OF EXCITEMENT
ABOUT A NEW TELL-ALL BOOK FROM
FORMER WHITE HOUSE STAFFER CLIFF
SIMS.
IT'S GETTING SO MUCH MEDIA
ATTENTION, YOU CAN SEE HERE IS
SIMS.
>> THE PRESIDENT AND I SITTING
JUST OFF THE OVAL OFFICE IN THE
PRIVATE STUDY AND WE ARE
CREATING WHAT AMOUNTS TO AN
ENEMIES LIST OF PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WHO I FELT WERE
BASICALLY DISLOYAL TO HIM.
>> HIS PENCHANT FOR PUTTING TWO
RIVAL STAFF MEMBERS IN A ROOM
AND LETTING THEM FIGHT IT OUT
OVER ISSUE DOES.
SOME OF THIS COMPETITIVE ASPECT.
IT'S ALREADY A TOUGH PLACE TO
WORK.
>> DID YOU EVER LEAK?
>> NOEL.
I TALKED ABOUT EVERYTHING I
SHOULD HAVE DONE DIFFERENTLY AND
THAT'S NOT ONE OF THEM.
I PUT MY NAME ON IT.
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SLAMMING SIMS, CALLING HIM "
"A LOW LEVEL STAFFER THAT I
HARDLY KNEW NAMED CLIFF SIMS
HE WAS NOTHING MORE THAN A
GOFER.
HE IS A MESS!"
LET'S GO OVER THE BIGGEST
REVIEW.
HE GOES INTO A KELLYANNE CAM
WAYS OFFICE AND YOU CAN -- ALL
THE REPORTERS.
SHE IS SAYING THAT SOMEONE ELSE
WHO'S LEAKING.
KELLYANNE SAYS THIS IS NONSENSE.
THE LEAKERS ARE THE ONES --
>> Jedediah: HE IS NOT
EMBARRASSED.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND PEOPLE WHO
SIGN THESE NDAs.
HAVING HIGH-LEVEL MEETINGS WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THEN CLEARLY
WANT TO BE ON TV AND SELL A
BOOK.
HE SHOULD GET SUED.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYTHING WILL
COME OF IT.
THIS GUY CAME OFF LIKE A WEASEL.
TALKING ON "NEW DAY" AND SHE
INTERRUPTS THE INTERVIEW AND
SAYS DO YOU KNOW THAT TRUMP
TWEETED.
HE GOES REALLY?
HE LOOKED LIKE A KID.
>> Dana: SO EXCITED, MORE
BOOKS.
>> Jedediah: LIKE I GOT
ATTENTION.
I WOULD CAUTION TRUMP AGAINST
THAT.
YOU GIVING THIS GUY MORE
ATTENTION THAN THE FACT THAT YOU
MIGHT DISLIKE HIM NOW OR YOU
HAVE A BEEF WITH HIM, IT'S ONLY
GOING TO MAKE THE MEDIA LOVE HIM
MORE.
WE CAN'T BELIEVE WE LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WHERE YOU CAN TAKE A
HIGH-PROFILE POSITION, YOU ARE
TRUSTED TO VALUE CONFIDENTIALITY
AND POTENTIALLY HIGH NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION AT TIMES
OUR HIGH SECURITY INFORMATION
AND YOU GO IN AND YOU ABUSE THAT
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE A JOB LIKE
THAT, YOU DECIDE I WANT TO WRITE
A TELL-ALL LIKE YOU RIGHTFULLY
ACQUIRE.
THIS GUY IS A JOKE.
>> Juan: I THINK HE WAS CHOSEN
BY TRUMP.
>> Jedediah: THAT'S ALL I'M
SAYING.
YOU CAN BE CHOSEN LIKE A
POSITION LIKE THAT.
IT'S A PRIVILEGE.
>> Juan: BOY, A LOT OF STRANGE
GUYS AROUND TRUMP.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING.
I NOTICED THAT THIS BOOK, EVEN
IF IT IS SOMEWHAT SALACIOUS AND
RIDICULOUS, IT FITS WITH WHAT
YOU HEARD FROM WOODWARD, MICHAEL
WOLFF, OMAROSA, CHAOS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Jesse: I AM ABOUT A THIRD
OF THE WAY THROUGH THE BOOK AND
I LIKE IT.
SEE, DANA, I DO READ.
>> Dana: EXCELLENT TASTE IN
BOOKS, JESSE.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU, DANA.
IT'S A POSITIVE PORTRAYAL OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY SAY HOW ENGAGING HE IS, HOW
INTELLIGENT HE IS.
HOW CONNECTED HE IS TO THE
PEOPLE.
IT WAS A FLATTERING PORTRAYAL OF
THE PRESIDENT, A FLATTERING
PORTRAYAL OF ABOUT 75% OF THE
REST OF THE PEOPLE.
HE HAD NEGATIVE THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT PAUL RYAN.
HE TOLD A GREAT STORY ABOUT HOW
TRUMP, THE MIDDLE OF AN
OVAL OFFICE MEETING, PAUL RYAN
IS BORING THE HECK OUT OF HIM
FOR 30 MINUTES ON HEALTH CARE
POLICY.
TRUMP JUST WALKS OUT AND STARTS
WATCHING TV IN THE DEN.
ALSO NEGATIVE PORTRAYAL OF
SEAN SPICER.
NOT A GOOD MANAGER.
THEY TAKE US THROUGH HOW THEY
DID THE WHOLE CROWD SIZE FIRST
PRESS CONFERENCE AND HOW IT WAS
A DEBACLE AND HOW HE STOLE A
MINI FRIDGE FROM ONE OF HIS
STAFFERS.
ALL IN ALL, THIS GUY IS FROM
ALABAMA.
DEVOUT CHRISTIAN.
HIS FATHER WAS A PASTOR AND HIS
MOTHER WAS A SUNDAY SCHOOL
TEACHER.
HE WAS A TED CRUZ SUPPORTER,
RUBIO GUY AND WAS DISGUSTED
AFTER THE "ACCESS HOLLYWOOD"
TAPE.
ALMOST LEFT THE CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
HE COULDN'T HANDLE IT AND THEN
HE SAID AS LONG AS HILLARY IS
NOT GOING TO BE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, I WILL STICK IT OUT
WITH TRUMP.
>> Jedediah: I'M GOING TO
STICK IT OUT AND THEN LEAK.
>> Jesse: AND THEN HE WROTE A
TELL-ALL.
>> Dana: I HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS ABOUT THIS.
A FRIEND OF MINE WHO KNOWS HIM
SUGGESTED THAT HE WANTS TO BE
ALABAMA'S OMAROSA WHICH IS NOT A
COMPLIMENT.
I DON'T CARE WHAT MAY HAVE
HAPPENED IN KELLYANNE'S OFFICE.
IF YOU ARE THE STAFFER ANYWHERE
THERE, AND YOU THINK IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE, YOU SHOULD
RESIGN.
IT'S HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE TO
THEN GO SELL A BOOK, ESPECIALLY
WHILE THE PRESIDENT IS STILL IN
OFFICE.
MAYBE THE BOOK PORTRAYS THE
PRESIDENT POSITIVELY, BUT IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY ARE IN A NEWS CYCLE THAT IS
NOT GOOD FOR THEM RIGHT NOW.
THIS GUY GOES OUT AND MAKES A
MILLION DOLLARS ADVANCE FOR A
BOOK, A MILLION DOLLARS ADVANCE
FOR THIS BOOK AND HE GOES OUT.
IT WILL BE HARD FOR HIM TO BE
TRUSTED AGAIN BY ANYONE.
HE'S A TALENTED YOUNG PERSON.
I THINK HE HAS -- HE HAD A LOT
OF PROMISE.
I THINK THIS IS A BAD DECISION.
HE COULD HAVE WRITTEN THIS BOOK
AFTER THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
WOULD'VE BEEN A BETTER TIME TO
DO IT.
>> Juan: HE SAYS JOHN KELLY,
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF, SAID IF
TRUMP WANTS TO FIRE ME IT WOULD
BE THE BEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
ANOTHER ADMISSION BY PEOPLE, OH,
YEAH, EVERYBODY WAS GOING TO BE
THE ADULT IN THE ROOM TO TRY TO
COUNTER TRUMP.
EVEN IN HIS OWN DESCRIPTION OF
WHY HE STAYED.
>> Greg: THERE IS NO TELL-ALL
IN THE HISTORY OF TELL-ALLS
THAT'S FLATTERING TO THE SUBJECT
OR THE TELL-ALL WOULDN'T EXIST.
WHEN YOU SIT DOWN WITH A
PUBLISHER, WERE THEY WANT IS
CONTROVERSY.
THEY WANT SCANDAL.
THEY PUSHED YOU AND PROD YOU TO
GET IT OUT.
WHEN YOU SUBMIT YOUR FIRST DRAFT
AND IT DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH CRAP
IN IT, THEY LOOK AT YOU LIKE YOU
BETRAYED THEM.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE MEDIA
GOBBLE IT UP LIKE CRACK ADDICTS
IN THE SENSE THAT THEY FORGET
IT'S AN EPHEMERAL HIGH.
IT OFTEN DOESN'T LAST AND IT'S
FALSE.
I DON'T LIKE THE FACT THAT THIS
GUY IS USING HIS DEVOUT
CHRISTIANITY AS A SHIELD.
IT'S A MONEY, DUDE.
IT'S NOT GOD.
IT'S GREEN THAT IS FORCING YOU
TO DO THIS.
NEVER GOING TO HAVE TWO
PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARIES.
A TRADITIONAL ONE AND ONE FOR A
TELL-ALLS.
TRUMP HAS NEVER BEEN BETTER THAN
ANYBODY FOR THE PUBLISHING
INDUSTRY.
MY LAST POINT AND I WILL SHUT
UP.
IF YOU ARE A CEO, IF YOU ARE A
BOSS, AN INTERESTING PERSON, IF
YOU'VE DONE A LOT, THE TELL-ALL
WILL COME AND IT BE BAD BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE WHO WRITE THE
TELL-ALL, THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
YOU.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHY YOU GET MAD.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHY YOU ARE
IMPULSIVE.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND YOUR
REASONING.
WHEN YOU ARE HAPPY ONE MINUTE
AND MAN THE OTHER OR YOU LEAVE
THE ROOM OR YELL AT SOMEBODY,
THEY ARE GOING HE'S OBVIOUSLY AN
AWFUL PERSON.
NO, YOU'RE JUST AN IDIOT AND YOU
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> Jesse: WHEN IS THE GUTFELD
TELL-ALL COMING OUT.
I'M GOING TO BUY IT.
>> Juan: I AM PLANNING NOW.
GREG, YOU WEREN'T BOTHERED THAT
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE OMAROSA AND
CLIFF SIMS ON THE INSIDE WITH